right good evening let's make a start if
that's okay everyone will hear me
clearly at the back said okay lovely
right now welcome tonight my name is
Danny Kendall I'm gonna be chairing
tonight's meeting in accordance with the
rules and procedures set out in the
front cover of your agendas before we
get started I could just remind
everybody members of the public that the
meeting is being recorded so it will be
available for you to re-watch at your
leisure over and over again if you want
to on YouTube in the next day or two and
if I can also remind people everybody in
the room to make sure their phones are
all silence as well or turned off
they'll be fantastic right shall we
start with a few introductions so if I
couldn't get the people on the top table
here to introduce themselves
Caroline Nash committee administrator
Ross chambers legal services
Tracy hub pre-planning services Jo
support planner and sim senior
development management officer at
Watcher County Council highways Jo Anne
Archer watch County Council to our
management highways team thank you and
Tracy could I ask you to explain your
role please Thank You chairman yes I'm
the planning manager for tonight's
meeting my role is to provide impartial
advice to clarify any planning issues
that arise and to assist members
decision-making in so doing I am bound
by the Royal Town Planning Institute
code of Professional Conduct and for the
avoidance of doubt planning committee
members are not bound by the advice of
officers or by their recommendations
Thank You Tracy right okay well that our
way move to apologies for absence please
yesterday my apologies received from
councillor Richards councillor Barnes
and councillor Adam for him council rock
is substituting it's wonderful thank you
thank you very much council rock
disclosure of interests from the
committee councillor Rock
1902 so2 six five eight five ful item
okay thank you thank you very much any
other declarations of interest no in
that case good idea as to talk about
item five first if that's okay because
we haven't any registered speakers for
that so if the committee are happy I'm
going to move that up to be dealt with
first if that's okay there are no
registered speakers this is item five
found on page 31 application reference
19 slash zero two three nine four slash
a very home farm main road loxias for a
variation of two can two conditions
within the permission the the reason it
was brought to committee was because it
was an objection from the parish council
and no one has registered from the
parish council to speak tonight
no one has registered to object in these
cases we usually have minded to delegate
it back for officers to make the final
decision I'm happy to propose that do I
have a seconder councilor parent thank
you all those in favor of delegating
that one back to officers please that's
thank you therefore application 19/2
zero two three nine four slash Barry its
delegated to officers for decision right
okay with that one out the way to normal
running order item three then is found
on page one of your agenda this is
application reference 19 slash 0 1 4 8
slash ful it's for guidance service
station
Bambi Road Gaiden and it's for the
demolition of all existing structures on
the site in the erection of a
replacement for court canopy pump Island
underground tanks and sales building
with associated car parking landscaping
and other associated works right
presenting opposite Joe Brooke over to
you thank you the application site is
located on the eastern edge of gayden on
the b4 100 as indicated by the black dot
for you
the main area of the site is occupied
occupied by an existing active fuel
station when an existing Associated
retail outlet also cited to the sofas
and the existing dryer and a former a
motif city on workshop the image before
you is Google Earth that shows you the
villages gayden the site is located
within the physical confines this is the
service station as you can see there's
open countryside to the west to the east
or across the site over the boundary
road is the greatest are listed in
Gaiden N and this is the recent
development of Spitfire homes just
access up here has at the m-40 and over
in this direction is Jaguar Land Rover
and light on heath development this is a
front shot of the service station itself
as you can see the spire shot the ISO
garage and so forth and that's a very
relatively new shot this is the exists
inside which is fronts on to the
Boundary Road to north of the existing
gaiden town centre pimpled Lane you can
see on the map for you is associated
that to the south of the site the
service station is roughly triangular in
shape with the existing building
situated so from forecourt and Parkinson
North the site currently comprises a
small shot from an ATM which is situated
Senshi within but really to the plot in
front this shop is a full court which
currently provides free fun pylons in
rectangular arrangement to the south of
the station a two type buildings the
residential dwellings at one point five
stories high with white when the
finished pit roof rear garden an area
standing the motor service goers were
associated forecourt and parking areas
is located directly to seven miles of
the dwelling but fronting on to the v4
100 answer there a mature hedgerow
situate surreal these buildings to there
in the open Kunj side you'll see photos
is further on this application is
seeking a number of aspects firstly did
the Massey existing buildings on the
site it's quite a new full court layout
and the provision of replacement pumps
and pump Islands a new canopy covered in
the pond pylons removal the existing
storage tanks and upgrading emplacement
revolvers power can lay out a new solar
field in which were quite two three
hundred twenty three point three square
meters and ciliary alterations to the
forecourt and associated work and this
is the elevation draw and take you from
the front of the be for 100 so as you
see the matter for you if you were
standing in the gate and village you
will be looking directly onto it the
only thing I would say about this
elevation you'll notice in the next one
it doesn't take into currently great in
the solid levels where the proposed one
does for that reason I say that because
this is now also front and on to the v4
100 so you can see the site level which
also takes it the shop would now be
located in the MOT service facility to
the south the site the rest of the area
would be opened up this it would be
taken from pintura lane or so really our
cultural field looking on to the gaben
village this is the front of shop so to
view this aspect you would have to be
standing in the forecourt and this is
the rear this would be taken from people
Lane the only difference being there is
proposed landscaping along this area
this shows the proposed shop retail
floor space and the different uses
associated insider this is a photo taken
from the beat for 100 look into surface
of the village is on the right gaze and
ins just there you can see the shop
canopy forecourt
this is the existing dwelling on the
front Gable on the garage in see the
close proximity to the two buildings and
associated park into the Amity garages
whether this is pimple lane that as the
MIT guards and the facade pimple lanes
got allowed to our other recent winners
there but you will see that in two
seconds this is the rear of the dwelling
so that's the petrol station service
shop just there before and hundred runs
directly in front that's the dwelling
across from pimple Lane so this is
standing room in the MOT forecourt and
the parking so that leave the neighbor
and right into the shop it's approved
this is taken from the agricultural
field just up above on him alone so you
can see the existing shop and the
Spitfire development just in the
background that Ed Zion sir and thwart
we hope there i didn't the v4 100 this
is a new development directly opposite
for homes and the new accesses can
create from it I see and the
preservation basically consideration the
existing lawful uses the site's contacts
previous planning history in statutory
and non-statutory contour tees the
application is considered to be in
coordinates for the area's development
time and there are no material planets
iterations to indicate otherwise
therefore officer recommendation is for
approval if you would take a minute to
have a look on the eight sheet there was
an update to the one of the previous
applications in 2016 was the suit that
was refused and there was an appeal the
subsequent
related enforcement notice was upheld by
the planning inspector on the 2nd of
October 2019 also there is a typo in the
community and structurally V section the
officers report it should be read in the
last paragraph however as expressed by
the community under stress early the
amendment regulations 2014 any
development that does not create a new
dwelling where the net internal layer is
less than 100 square metres is exempt
for using the application results in a 0
tonight simply satori from gross than
that which I apologize for thank you
Thank You Jo all right okay we got our
first speaker council Adrian Claxton
gate and parish council please welcome
counselor okay right so yeah on three
minutes if you'd remain seated the end
at that time for any questions that the
committee may have for you would you
like a warning the last ten seconds okay
gayden parish council objects the
application on the following grounds the
increasing traffic generation concern
concerns in the amount of traffic being
brought into the village road access
concern for the safety of traffic
exiting pimple lane environmental
impacts littering flooding as seen
recently recently the end of pit lane
floods in severe weather additional
drainage will be required concerns for
an increase in light and noise pollution
the demolition of a perfectly
serviceable bungalow considered
detrimental to the housing needs of the
village the applicants appeal for appeal
for dispensation to cs20 does not apply
in this case as the development does not
consume community benefit the property
is only empty because it has not been
put on the market and the design being
cited optic a great two listed building
there is an
sense of place to this development this
retail outlet also poses a risk to the
local community run shop which is a
village asset when before 100 was a
major trunk road and gayden had to
hostelries it it made sense to have a
petrol station in this location with the
air vent at the m-40 and the gate and
bypass is no longer a prime position for
a petrol station but this application is
not about the petrol station it's about
the additional franchises for which
previous planning applications have been
rejected and now on now subject to
enforcement the addition of these
franchises has created parking problem
and the additional litter problem in the
village the washing and planning
addendum is the state at letter states
the changes proposed are not intended to
expand or alter the function of the
existing service station on this site
this is wrong as the existing services
on this site subjects of planning
enforcement so the existing state of the
services is an artificial state with the
implanting impending enforcement if this
was the case if what their original
statement was the case where would be
the business case for a proposed the
proposed investment although WCC
highways have given no objections this
application on the base of a desktop
study they have not appreciated the
parking issues created by having these
franchises on the site neither this
application nor previous rejected
applications cater for the type of
traffic that these franchises create as
can be seen from the photographs which
can various photograph you scroll
through them the arrow the yellow arrow
to indicate past vehicles as you see
from the photographs ATVs and farm
vehicles cause obstructions to the road
and the pavement in the vicinity of the
adjacent crossroads and damages to the
verges
none of the road safety audits address
issues caused by vehicles parking
outside the safety sight was like that's
the klaxon so you have to stop and stop
you there you've reached your three
minutes apologies and that committee
have any questions for the parish
council councillor Perry I just I've got
a couple of queries if I may
could you just advise when the most
recent housing needs survey by the
parish council was undertaken recently
but if you haven't done one can you just
explain what well this is a bungalow
it's in in the council there was a need
for bungalows right in in this with an
aging population in this village and
would I be right in thinking there was
the earth a couple of bungalows on the
Spitfire development yes you build
yes which have been the other query I
just wanted to raise is that you have
highlighted your concern about increase
of traffic now obviously it's operating
as a fuel station and a shop at the
moment can you just explain why you
think there will be a significant
increase of traffic well obviously as a
business they're expanding the site by
adding extra fuel pumps they are because
of its the franchises they are drawing
traffic into the village and I don't
know how urogram Rogers advertised but
obviously that it's in their interest to
advertise to people who use the m-40 to
draw traffic off the m-40 where their
fuel and services are potentially
cheaper than what work services
further down the road counselor Jennings
just for a bit of clarification is there
another petrol station is there another
petrol station or the petrol station
there perhaps is there another petrol
station is there another petrol station
that there is a petrol station currently
on that site is there another one not in
the village no no there's other work
services or the other new one so I'm
just trying to get an idea of a layout
yeah okay thank you any other questions
from the committee
no that case Casa klaxon thank you very
much for your time thank you so we get
our next speaker now Laura Beach please
the agent for the applicant welcome as
well same rules apply you have three
minutes if you'd remain for any
questions at the end and I'll give you a
warning at ten seconds if that's okay
thank you
and firstly and you'll be aware that the
site has been a subject of alternative
proposals in the past an application was
submitted in 2018 for redevelopment of
the petrol station and adjoining land to
provide a new service station with a
drive-through coffee shop that
application was refused and dismissed
appeal but Yura carriages has taken this
review on board and listened to the
feedback from the Planning Inspectorate
it's important to point out that the new
proposal before you today is for a
substantially different scheme the
proposal has been scaled down the
drive-through coffee shop has been
removed and there's no longer any
development on green fill land the
proposal addresses all of the concerns
raised in the 2018 planning appeal
secondly I turned to some of the issues
raised by the parish council it's been
suggested that the scheme will generate
more traffic on local roads with impacts
on highway safety this is not the case
traffic flow is not expected to change
materially new custom is likely to come
from people who already use the local
roads already passed by the site but are
now encouraged
use the redeveloped facility the
proposed layout of the site will improve
vehicle circulation preventing
congestion and ensuring its operate
safely Comfort should also be taken from
the fact that your highways Authority
has reviewed the proposal and raised no
objection to the scheme in fact to quote
their consultation response it stated
the proposal will actually provide
significant betterment in comparison to
the existing site layouts we understand
there's also concern regarding the local
community shop and it's important to
recognize that the shop already trades
alongside the petrol station without any
issue the kiosk will only increase in
size by a small amount and this is
mainly to provide more customer
circulation space there's no planning
reason at all while a kiosk and shop
cannot continue to complement each other
and coexist so in summary there are no
adverse impacts associated with a
development and have been no objections
received from statutory console TV in
fact the scheme should be welcomed
because it provide a range of benefits
for the site in the village it will
modernize the existing petrol station
providing a more efficient and spacious
layout with new facilities such as
electric car charging points it will
modernize and upgrade the with this
devastation the applicant has also
worked closely with the council to
ensure the design of the new kiosk is of
a high standard it will be attractive
and make good use of glazing to create
an active street frontage and local
materials to complement surrounding
buildings
it's there'll also be a reduction in the
built form on the sides which will help
to open up views of the countryside
behind and it will be complemented by an
attractive landscaping scheme providing
37 new trees finally the proposal will
expand a business generating economic
activity which has to be encouraged and
providing potential for additional local
job creation the application is fully in
accordance with the development plan and
there are no outstanding planning
reasons why the current application
should not be approved in light of the
recommendation very much perfectly time
thank you right do we have any questions
from committee
Casa Perry thank you hello good evening
you mentioned the size of the shop is a
little bit bigger how much bigger in
percentage terms is it than the existing
four
I'm not sure as a percentage I believe
it's 90 square meters which is mainly
just to make it quite cramped in the
shop at presence is to allow more space
for the customers to sort of cue
circulate and there might be a small
increase in the offer but it's it's
quite a small amount in retail but it's
an ciliary to the petrol station but if
if it was a retail use it wouldn't
require any kind of impact assessment
because it is such a small quantum my
other query was with regard to the
lighting of the retail unit because at
present if I'm right on its orientation
I have been - I have been armored or
have occasionally on the customer that
at that station it's by by moving the
the shop that way the lighting will go
that that way or because I know that was
in past being some issues on lighting
coming straight forward to the road what
are your plans on the lighting of the
retail outlet will now be sort of turned
to a different angle so the outlook and
perspective there will be slightly
different but I also know that there are
various conditions in which would deal
with lighting okay Council Rock I
wondered if you saw some of the pictures
I think probably shared by the parish
council of principal agricultural
vehicles and all those sort of big you
know various local people you took
you're alluding to the fact that though
it will serve as local people and this
is an agricultural area as we see there
JCB's and so forth past tracks I mean
that does suggest there might be a bit
of a problem in some of the local
customers that you're seeking to attract
this expanded area I just wondered if
you had any comment on that
the coat it's a difficult one for me to
comment on because that's gotten really
nothing to do is sort of the site itself
we can't control where we're not some
encouraging H TVs or tractors to park
there and that's to do with the current
petrol station there'll be no change to
whatever the situation referred to with
the current application I only mention
it because you you said you were hoping
to attract local custom this is an
agricultural area you're not trying to
drop a flame from the m42 you said these
were agricultural vehicles and you're
expanding it so it just seemed an
interesting point that the territory
rocks I'm gonna have to press you for a
question here rather than just a chat oh
thank you you don't have to shut up if
you've got a question we need to get to
it okay right if there are no further
questions in that case thank you very
much for your time as well right okay so
no other speakers move to accounts the
kettle our ward member welcome
councillor kettle so you know the
routine you have five minutes over to
you
Thank You mr. chairman firstly I start
off by rebutting the suggestion that if
you build a shop at 323 square meters to
replace one of 230 I think it is you
don't do that and they're expecting
considerable increase in football so
suggest there is going to be a no
increase in traffic mix it'll just
service local population is poppycock
why do you expand a shop by almost 50%
and this should expect sales to increase
by 50% supermarkets etc base their
profitability on squalor
sales per square foot
and we are doubling it or increasing my
50% here so I think just take let's just
be serious here there's going to be a
significant increase in traffic
had it been a kiosk I quite agree one
that see very little change but this is
not a kiosk this is an all-singing
all-dancing shop it says so in the slide
in front of you we've seen an earlier
description of all the aisles that we
have we don't have any aisles in the
current shop it just doesn't exist so
this is a mini supermarket and not that
many at this stage why are we going to
build that because we want more
customers in so I don't we anyway
I'd like to go to the planning history
the current site which Joe and I have to
say he's worked incredibly hard on this
site mr. Brook I should say and he has
been very good keeping the Parish
Council and myself fully informed all
the way through not just this
application blown previous ones I'd like
to congratulate him on the hard work and
the way he's addressed this application
sometimes it's been quite difficult but
because with previous agents has been
their response but look at the planning
history we had a retrospective about
three respective applications all of
which were refused two of them were
taken to appeal the appeals were refused
there has been an improvement in the
design but consistently what has
happened is mr. sim from highways has
objected time after time to highways
concerns on this site one inspector did
not believe that highways was reason for
a refusal and refused it on other
grounds and but have we seen any
significant change what worries me is
that Warren County Council having had a
consistent approach to refusal because
of one inspector not all of them one
inspector has refused to accept highways
as an issue and I would like you to ask
then why at a later stage in the meeting
he feels that this is not acceptable
the police have carried out surveys on
this which have shown significant
speeding and I'm slightly concerned
then may not have seen the police
surveys that was afforded by the parish
council to hopefully it would have gone
I've seen it and it shows consistent
speeding between the be for 100
roundabouts on this site in addition we
are having two new bus stops built under
a previous application on each side of
the road in close proximity to this site
so let's just take into account that
I've already talked about the agents not
speaking at no stage has been any
consultation between the developer and
the parish despite the fact there have
been five separate applications not once
has anybody come to us the Paris opinion
or the local population opinion or my
popular my opinion page 13 Joe says that
the property has all the shop has been
continuing with the continuous lawful
use that's not quite accurate because in
fact a significant part of the shop has
been subject to respect application
which was refused by this council and
refused as appeal that refused that the
enforcement notice we issued was also
appealed and refused and they've now
been given six months to not not that
part of property down that is not a
continuous lawful use of the site
economic impact there is already a shop
in Bishop's as a shopping and sorry
engaging there's already a shop in kind
so there's a shop in Bishop's itching to
we need to consider as particle strategy
the economic impact or developments and
that my belief is that this very
overstated supermarket has gained have a
dire impact on existing local businesses
and there's also one in light on Heath
which is not in my ward and I'm very
concerned about the loss of jobs that
might take place in these other twenty
seconds thank you
I very much like you to go to highways
in terms of conditions I'd like a
condition on when the shop is open so
there's not open 24/7 and I'd also like
a condition to protect the impact on
the houses on the other side of pimple
lane because they face straight onto the
back of this and I think that's
unacceptable thank you thank you very
much any questions for our ward member
council rock Thank You chairman good
evening Council except or you alluded in
the last few words of your delivery and
in your comments about the competition
with other local retail outlets and you
talked about the core strategy I just
wondered if you don't happen to know
passages that we might be able to
examine later on in here or should we
ask the planning officer that later
stage Thank You mr. Rock I've some said
the MPP F not the core strategy I'm not
a three kept there are three issues
socially you can all make a mark on what
third one is but we need to focus here
on the economic impact of existing
businesses replacing a kiosk that sells
burgers is one thing but actually the
damage that we got to shops in kind too
and we've got one a bishop since you
know we've got one light on peas and we
have the community store all over a
hundred yards away from this site if you
put an all-singing all-dancing shop here
it's going to drag in significant extra
traffic but don't traffic is going to be
pulled away from local stores which will
mean that we'll have additional vehicles
driving in there additional you know it
is not just a sustainable sustainable on
that basis any further questions okay if
councillor kettle thank you
right okay that's our speakers tom
points of clarification from the
committee they don't have any questions
yes counselor Perry Thank You chairman I
wonder whether the planning team can
advise if we were minded to grant
regarding and conditions specifically
relating to shop opening hours because
obviously with the pollution of light
impacting on the residential community
question I was going to ask does it have
opening hours already the shop does have
open and we'd be keeping those know if
you have a look quite have in
recommended put hours of for the shop to
be open as a condition it's under
condition 13 I've already put as a
recommendation sorry I know you've could
you be a bit more specific in terms of
the actual hours which I think would be
helpful for members of the committee the
recommended hours would be about 11
o'clock so I'll be for the hours of the
shop use only but like I said is only
for the shop new to the petrol station
would still be used at the year okay
catalytics question for the plan is the
economic impact it's that a planning
concern when looking at obviously the
parish council and the district
councillor considers that the expansion
of this unit will have a detrimental
impact on of the business units in the
vicinity is that a consideration we
should have in our mind at all not on
this CAU is the honest answer on the
major major scheme such a retail that
huge outlets and stuff like that you
often then do a sequential tests and so
forth on open and small scale schemes
like this it's open market competition
Council Rock can we just have some
clarity over the enforcement issue with
regard to the current site please I'll
go first
so let me go to the musician shop so
fundamentally though he's absolutely
correct there was unlawful development
in this area that stunt and as you say
you've been to the shops you know the
Gregg's area in the shop that was
unlawfully bill so it was a real
proportion here which changed the layout
as well
highways fundamentally
get to the application when to appeal we
wouldn t appeal and enforcement know it
was able to reorient eight and bring
them back that was then went to appeal
and that's what the only update she is
that's reasonably that's from recently
upheld by Deena spectra
I hope okay any other questions show you
out to the debate maybe want to start
council para you seem clean don't know
whether I'm keen didn't seem to be
anybody else sticking their thumb up and
someone's got to actually start as I
mentioned earlier I am familiar with the
site because I work in Clinton and
sometimes have to go down to light torn
he thick wearing my other hat so
declaring an interest I have I do use
the petrol station from time to time
when I can't get anywhere else that's a
little less expensive and I'm right on
empty having said that I am familiar
visiting the site both at all times of
day and in the dark and one of the
things the lighting from the current
shop actually shines forward back onto
the road and from a design perspective I
actually think this is a much cleaner
and better obviously it's an enlarged
site but we will be using there is there
are two buildings involved one is the
MOT garage which would obviously go and
this bungalow that he's kind of
sandwiched in between the petrol station
and the garage so I think from an
aesthetic perspective actually it sort
of cleans up the whole site and from
from that perspective I'm struggling
actually to find a planning reason to
refuse it because I actually think
together with the local housing need the
parish
Saul advised that they haven't recently
done a housing needs survey so the
argument of losing upon a bungalow to me
doesn't doesn't sit comfortably with
that particular concern because they
haven't done a housing needs survey plus
the development of opposite this
particular site incorporates a number of
bungalows and I know there are some
properties still for sale or I believe
there are still some properties for sale
on that site so on the basis of the
absence of any strong planning material
reason I will be going along with the
officers recommendation thank you I
think you've said you've said well I was
thinking as well councillor Rock that
I've got count so Jennings yeah dance
upon encounter Dixon because question
and I'm count the post points I think I
really quite germane to the whole
consideration firstly on on the
questions are light pollution I don't if
there's a picture that shows the
orientation of this in respect to the
road network and a plan so these windows
did they don't shine light of up the
road as you approach the site because of
the curvature of the road or anything to
us you won't see light shining out a
supermarket path as you approach it from
a distance that's not that doesn't need
to be screened was it screened by the
petrol pumps that's a that's a thought
I'm not listening to cancel it Perry
there I think as care for Perry said we
would be struggling to find reasons to
oppose this I think there are concerns
about you officer talked about the
sequential test on but I mean this is
you know in fact a mini supermarket in
the mid of the countryside but the
officers are advising us the scale is is
not such that if it was a bigger
operation we will be worried about that
there's the small shops in these
villages but we don't seem to have
enough scale to be able to reasonably
refuse it is the advice we've got
but that's a concern I do share with the
speakers but frankly it doesn't seem to
be crossing the threshold where we can
oppose it the hours of operation and the
light pollution are things that you know
I would emphasize we do want the
officers to think about that very
carefully in the conditions aren't
concerned about these pictures we've
seen about the parking and so forth
quite what we can do about that I don't
know the operators obviously think
there's money to be made here they think
it's an economically feasible scheme
that means attracting local traffic some
of that's going to be big vehicles but
if I always think it's okay again we're
we're struggling to say that's a reason
on its own to raise objection so I'm not
terribly happy with it but I think
there's not enough weight for us to say
it's it's something we can really carry
objects us for Thank You Kath so Janet
I'm looking at the scale of this and it
doesn't look over overly large a lot a
lot of it's used up with storage and in
some ways if you have a place like this
with a lot of storage it means that less
frequent deliveries oversized compared
to a lot of petrol stations I've been
into and I'm sort of struggling I'd be
struggling to argue against it purely
through the scale of it I said I'm
struggling to obviously with previous
applications have been refused and I
think there's probably a good reason for
it but I can't see any reasons on
they've actually put in a good
application this time so this is
probably why everyone seems to be in
favor people are struggling to come up
with a reason why we shouldn't thank you
sometimes if you can't find a reason not
to
maybe you should so I mean you know I
think you have been aired in debate I'm
in total agreement I'm happy proposed
that we propose grant on this I would
look for a seconder
obviously councillor Dixon thank you so
the we have proposed or a seconder that
we granted this application which we go
to vote all those in favor please show
that for German those against and
abstentions
two abstentions okay therefore the
committee resolves to grant application
reference 19 slash zero one four zero
eight slash ful move to our next item on
the agenda which is item four and found
on page 19 right okay item for that this
is on page 19 application reference 19
slashes 0 2 6 5 8 slash ful the land to
the rear of Bicknell school Lane pries
Martin has been Marsten sorry and this
is the election of wand Welling with
detached garage presenting officer Joe
Brooke again Joe over to you thank you
the application is located on the
eastern edge of prize Marston as
indicated by the black top for you the
salt is located within the boys
mastering Conservation Area the boundary
which runs along the eastern side
boundary so that is the conservation
areas bill I'm angry that Purple Line
sorry for instance the site is actually
as far as school Lane and no three roads
serving a number of other residential
properties including and property known
as Bicknell which seats sits to the west
of the site
nice bit not just that and a neighbor
known as Laurel Bank so dollar bank is
directly adjacent to the river just
there and then to the psychics on the
south side Westar Westwood house is a
greater listed neighboring building that
sits approximately 45 minutes to west
south of sorry
so the listed build in Westwood is the
rad building for you
this is a Googler shot of the
application site initially to rear there
he's still quite heavy overgrown us
north that's he change very much that
school lane westward Becnel and Laurel
Bank is that one the site is trying to
the north and south and east by open
areas of product line gardens associated
with the large properties a public
footpath runs adjacent to the northern
side banking travels in an east-west
direction however this is outside a
redline boundary and our search is
unaffected by the development proposal
the application is seeking planning
permission to construct a single twin
into the rear of law bank on Westwood
House as described before the solicited
bill in the West with house and that his
lower bank and that his Becnel and the
blue boundary the application if
approved would allow the construction of
a two-story trailing with a double
gabled appearance that's always worried
eight point five minutes Holly while the
planet Earth has a maximum of fifteen
point six meters the applicant is
proposing to construct the 12-hour plain
clay tile course natural stone and
rustic red brick with oak frame finishes
the plan before you depicts the floor
plans which are proposed and this is the
elevation to the garage which is
proposed that the same material would be
set at five point six minutes to Ridge
where an overall dimension of six meters
by five point seven meters this is the
access site into it so that this is
taken from school lane leading up into
the application so that's taken bearing
from the application site to write you
is lower bang-on Bicknell oil means
ideal her photos if you wish this is the
application so as you can see it has
become very heavily overgrown
that's the open public
to the east and a large residential
properties been aforementioned
that is garage that you just saw such
lead-in guarantee access along school
Lane that's Laurel Bank which is too
rare the application so it that's across
the open pallets to the east the large
residence dwelling over to the east and
that is that school lane leading
directly up in south coast so that the
site would be situated way behind
Westwood house which is the grade two
stylists to build and by the way in
consideration the inspectors decision
which got an approval of this very
scheme and the area's development plan
including the latest material
considerations such as a draft site
allocation plan and the prize master and
perish plan the principal development
has been established and the application
is not considered to cause undue harm to
landscape character nearby heritage
assets and the prize Marston
Conservation Area consequently officer
recommendation is for approval there are
no updates and thank you thank you Jeff
right okay go to our first speaker
counsel John Franklin prize master and
parish council please welcome counselor
hello you do one in the middle that's
the one perfect so you have three
minutes if you'd remain seated for any
questions at the end
you're warned in ten seconds over to you
thank you our original concerns
regarding over development of this plot
reduction in green space and you saw how
lovely the green spaces were in the
village environs the negative impact and
surrounding properties the unsuitability
of X's for a singletrack name with no
possibility of a suitable parking area
passing area and the proximity of the
school still remain we stray those
concerns
we do however accept that these subject
of objections were not consider
sufficient by the inspector who thought
fit to grant the Planning Commission
however since the original planning
application has lapse
and we believe that the new one must be
considered on his own merits as I have
already mentioned in our original
objections remained furthermore we
believe the application should be
rejected for the following additional
reasons the core strategy and the parish
plan have both been adopted since the
original application in both plans the
need for smaller to three-bedroom
properties has been a clearly identified
there is no need for more larger
properties limited numbers of larger
houses have already been built and the
quota has been exceeded since the
original application 10 new homes have
been built in the village which is only
a category 4 village and these have
provided a further 44 bedrooms now that
gives you an indication of the size of
the properties that have been approved
planning approval is given to too many
if planning permission is given to too
many more large properties it is
difficult to see how the housing me it
can ever be addressed and the housing
stock bounds corrected more than 50% of
our housing is 4 bedrooms or more what
we need is two and three-bedroom houses
and just to be clear this is not a self
build the plot has remained on the
market under sell for more than three
years at the time of the original
application
there was no built-up area boundary for
the village and as such the application
was granted despite being in the edge of
the village and in green countryside the
proposed built-up area boundary prize
master now shows this to be outside the
permitted building area and therefore we
believe planning should not be granted
if planning is to be granted for
buildings suitable outside the build up
area of boundary that it should only be
exceptional circumstances this cannot be
considered a circumstance of such
character finally I have to mention our
local communities these are severely
overstretched notably Southern College
where the accounts for the committee
will be aware that there's a moratorium
on planning because of the place is
there and the possibly more
ten seconds the potential close to the
local doctor surgery which can only be
increased though the pressure
lovely any questions please from
committee
count Sperry can you just confirm when
your local housing needs survey was
carried out was that part of the parish
any other questions please that case
Council thank you very much for your
time we can go to our next speaker is
because sorry Nick Fulford and Paul
Stockport or just one of you you have
three minutes
again same rules apply if you'd stay
seated for any questions is already on
that was already on its go very much was
here three and a half years ago with
this planning committee found it was a
proposal that this should be granted and
it was thrown out unanimously there's no
reason to think in the last three and a
half years anything has changed in fact
it's been specifically mentioned in the
application that nothing has changed so
it might be very reasonable to expect
this planning committee to also throw it
out housing survey seemed to be very
important and out had conducted this
year 2019 with the explicit point that
no development of this size was
necessary it's also been a very poor
marketing situation that hasn't sold in
three years more importantly of course
we all know now that the the built up
area boundary has now moved and this
property is now an open countryside
outside of it and therefore should be
declined as an application nearly
finally can the Appeal decision that was
granted
three years ago point 18 clearly says
vehicle passing place is to be provided
the most recent application seems to
ignore this there was some kiss
conditions in the appeal that obviously
can't be addressed until the site is
addressed this is one thing that might
have been addressed in the plan and in
the drawing and it just illustrates the
contempt of this application hands to
this process and I could go on to
mention traffic around the school I
couldn't have been parking and drainage
or lack of drainage in our villages
floods regularly but I think mr.
chairman I've concluded my statement
thank you very much mister stop any
question is please from the committee in
that case thank you very much for your
time as well thank you I can support us
through now we have David postions
please was it persons postures thank you
so as the agent for the applicant you
have combination of the previous two
speakers time which was three minutes
each they have six minutes
thank you remain seated for any
questions at the end and I'll give you a
warning at ten seconds over to Yusef I
don't think I need the full six
hopefully my main tenet is that this
application has been assessed three
times by three separate individuals
three separate professionals two of your
own flying offices Lucy Hammond was the
first one and Josie was the second one
and planning inspector and all three of
them have found that this proposal is
and complies with all current local and
national plan policy so there are no
there are no good planning reasons why
this should not be approved and that
really is my main argument three
professionals who look at these policies
day in and day out have determined that
this and it is the same application this
is essentially a renewal of one which
expired because the applicant was a bit
slow or say so and that is my main thing
one thing I would also like to just
address a couple of points that
raise the built-up area boundary hasn't
changed the built barrier boundary is
the built barrier boundary and it does
go around the outside of the site that's
in the s AP I think got a copy with me
but I have had a copy I'm sure that your
planning team will back me up on that
one the other thing I would say is that
in three years since the appeal was
allowed the playing policy hasn't
changed it was done under the current
playing policies and their current
adopted plan and the things like that
could skew it like the five-year housing
land supply that hasn't changed there
was a five-year housing the land supply
when this was granted last time so
that's not something that could be
called into question and really like to
say from me there are no good planning
reasons why this should be refused it's
been say three professionals Dean that
it's in accordance with policy and I
just ask that you assess it on those
merits on its accordance with policy
thank you very much do we have any
questions from committee
nobody else'll Dixie yeah go for it we
heard from a previous objector that no
change has been made to this plant in
any way yes I see the inspector did
suggest the introduction of a passing
bait have you given that any thought yes
I have it's it's not clear on the plan
where the red lines and spreads out as
it comes out of the drive the intent is
to take part of the lawn which is
beloved which owns is owned by Bicknell
just to make the drive a little bit
wider okay so there will be a passive
place well they absolutely will yeah
thank you
thank you thank you chair good evening
can you advise what consultation you've
undertaken in terms of engagement with
the local parish council please I don't
believe we've had any engagement with
the first council it's just been a
standalone application okay there are no
further questions if there's parcels
thank you very much if you think you
right for clarification committee do we
have any questions
oh sorry I'm so sorry counselor Rock
apologies come on in of course not I'm
sorry
moving on to other questions in perhaps
I've got a few written to hear myself
sorry Kel Surratt you've got five
minutes no perhaps thirty seconds of
course I can
well we're on the present application
revolves around the plan inspectors
decision and what's changed since then
so I'll confine my comments to those
change circumstances since the appeal
could have done more
oh you've done it already first of the
emerging science and equations plan
identifies a severe over supply of
houses in the areas shown and calls for
a moratorium on significant house
building this includes pliers master
would have shown with the circle this is
because of secondary school places are a
problem in the seventh catchment and
Bob's teams are you probably all know
told me a month or so ago the college is
under pressure now facing many rules
replaces the planning inspectors report
specifically said that she'd seen no
evidence relating to housing needs we
now have that evidence the parish plan
only adopted by the district council
this year based on the prize master
housing needs survey expresses housing
needs for only a small number of two to
three bedroom houses since the planning
inspectors decision ten houses have been
permitted as we've already heard in
prize master and go and well beyond
their housing needs so we have an
oversupply of houses both in price
Mastan and the wider area of the sap
good at the next slide please
since the inspectors decision we now
have an adopted process for determining
the confines of settlement which we did
not have three years ago the plumbing
inspector was therefore not able to
consider our current methodology which
we're now adopted this is the built-up
area in the sap at the moment our
processor what neither have included the
site in the built-up area boundaries in
2016
and after date day according to plant
plumbing policy neither does it now
slide three please
in fact the proposed at b2b rate B was
only extended to include this side which
is open countryside in three sides
because of this appeal decision as a
permission is no longer extant the site
is defined as being outside the village
conference by that process thus today
this site is upper development in open
countryside moving on to environment
considerations this is a semi Wooden's
wooded site and it seems to me five may
be up to ten mature trees would be lost
by this development maybe more the four
counts was passed a climate emergency
motion the cabin has endorsed a work
plan respond to that which will include
enhanced SPD's which are been informed
in writing include measures to promote
and preserve trees so this is an
emerging an additional consideration
we've heard from the occupants of the
adjacent house but that's slide four
please the planning inspectors report
makes no mention of the recent extension
then which faces the application site
the peel was done by written
representation with evidence taken me
months before so it seems fairly clear
that this new principle ever elevation
of the neighboring house facing the much
higher levels of the application site
and extended towards it where there will
be traffic parking garage and etc for a
six bedroom house overlooking the
amended private amenity space of that
adjacent has its Laurel Bank will be
greater the passing Bay has been alluded
to there is a very small pond on the
site which fret ecological consideration
needs to be made and the planet
inspector and the officer and correct
and the need for a passing play on-site
but it's difficult to see how a turning
area can be arranged within the side
note in the wildlife planned pond not
shown on the plans and the other private
spying parking spaces that are also not
shown on the plans so to summarize if
the committee's minded to grant I ask
you apply a condition
a construction management plan including
parking and protection of wildlife
during construction also there should be
a lighting condition due to the very
countryside location and neighbor
potential nuisance however I believe the
application should be refused because of
the changed circumstances since the last
application was permitted including
increased uses including increased
issues with neighbor privacy and the
following it is development in Oakland
countryside which does not meet only the
exception test in is 10 items a2j there
is no housing need justification either
in the village or in the wider area it
is contouring to see 30 second paragraph
D or F and is contrary to cs50 in the
housing provision and that whole section
thank you very much committee thank you
Thank You councillor
any questions for the ward member no
that case counselor ah thank you very
much for your time as well now we could
get a points of clarification all right
lovely stuff that's the parrot Thank You
chair I've got two points actually I'd
like some clarification on what weight
can we give to the 2019 parish plan and
in particular drawing attention to the
need for smaller units and also can I
have a clarification on the weight of
the draft be UAB please certainly in
regards to in regards to the pirate plan
it's not adopted policy so it doesn't
carry full weight and termination
applications it is a material
consideration but it has to have a
limited way in the determination because
it's not doctor policy it hasn't been
through formal examination it hasn't
even been out for public consultation so
it is a material acceleration but it
doesn't carry that weight the house
needs survey done as part of the Paris
plan often they're more the rise for
local knees dwellings to be honest so if
there was a member in
on the village that was looking for a
two-bedroom house I managed to get
self-build unit you could condition it
regarding the Harrison need survey
because this is a category for service
village as depict avoid CS 16 the core
strategy and the principal has I've
stated him report under CS 15 is 10 and
the C 16 is acceptable the principal
have in the dwelling this area is
considered in accordance with the areas
divided plan and they carry full weight
and determination this application in
regards to the second question
so it's Joffe AV ok it's dry off stage a
minute so it's a material consideration
so it carries limited weight similar to
the post planner see it's recently gone
consultation so it's got a bit more
weight you carry more weight the further
you get to examination but it's still
limited but if you also know in the
principle section myself the foremost
Lucy Hammond and the planning inspector
of also undertook a physical confines
test which is depicted in the course
tragic so the core strategy stage within
the be UAB where the find and or if it's
not find physical confines so both for
settlement having undertook I just just
completely clarify this this is still
inside the built barrier boundaries as
it stands now and then the draft which
is gone tired to consultation this is
being promoted as being in the built up
area boundary thank you any other
questions
yes council Jennison the tree issue was
brought up at trees going and I was just
quickly looking at the condition there's
a tree protection scheme what's involved
in that condition so a tree protection
skin you have model conditions and to be
honest they report for enforce body
inspector so a lot the wordings already
done
they've got detailed landscaping details
of how these trees are going to protect
it which trees and hedges and so forth
because I also record on landscaping
condition are going to be maintained how
they're going to be kept for at least
five years
they should be protected in accordance
with standards I can't say it straight
off top my head and various things like
that so they all come to consultation to
us we will go through the protection
scheme if it's not satisfactory the
honest truth is you refuse the discharge
and then they have to go back out and do
it until we prove appropriate skin in
accordance with the British Standards
any other questions okay shall we go to
the debate Council Perry thank you I
appreciate it Thank You chairman first
of all I think I would like to express
my sympathies with the Parish Council
and the objecting neighbors because on
the face of it personally I don't like
what I see in front of me the biggest
issue I have is I haven't got a material
planning reason to refuse it
particularly in view in mind the history
attached to this particular site we have
the planning inspector with the appeal
and then we have all the other things so
my concern is that if we were to go down
the route of refusal it would go to
appeal and we would lose it
but that doesn't stop me saying that I
think personally I think it's over
development it's very sad that a pat
when a parish council puts a lot of
effort into putting together a very
valuable parish plan but it has to be
ignored I would much rather see a couple
of two or three-bedroom properties on
this site but that's not to be so I'm
going to be forced to go with the
officers recommendation apologies to the
neighbouring objectors in the parish
council you can't spare anybody else
want to speak on this
countess Lowe Jennings I would lock my
thoughts on it and I think if we
to refuse this get granted it appeal and
I think we've got quality we get stung
with the builders well because let's say
we've already granted this one thank you
can strain account seven thank you
Castle Rock did mention about a
potential extra condition about the
lighting going out onto the open
countryside is that something we might
be able to consider Thank You councillor
Sherman it potentially wouldn't it
wouldn't be typical I think to put a
lighting condition on for a single
dwelling if because obviously individual
dwellings can add lighting security
lighting and so forth on to their
properties without necessarily directly
needing planning permission if members
felt that it was of such overriding
concern that you wanted to add one we
could do so but I think officer advice
would be is that that wouldn't be
typical for a single dwelling Thank You
counsel Jennings with the lighting
security lighting on there it's gonna
come on it's ready struggle to justify
that I think I think it would be an
unreasonable condition to be honest
really if you live there hope you will
probably want some security lighting and
it will be infrequent when it goes on
but when it does go on to be necessary
happening so I think it'd be an
unreasonable thing to ask right we don't
have a proposition yet but I get the
feeling the committee's going in a
particular direction towards grant don't
really like frozen for the chair but I
think I'll agree I have to propose that
we go with this on the ground so I have
a second second by councillor Perry if
nobody else wants to speak on this the
proposition is that we grant it's been
seconded all those in favor in that case
the committee resolves to grant
application 19 slashes zero to six five
eight slash ful our last application of
there's no urgent business that I'm
aware of the only thing to say I think
actually is tonight
then I think it's your last meeting with
us so I think on behalf of the committee
like to say thank you for all the time
you've given to us over the years it's
quite a lot of time over the years now
it's really far it's a long long time so
thank you very much from this committee
all the best in the future right there
we go that case the meetings closed
thank you very much everybody